So, let's redraw this sampling distribution. So, if this is the mean of the
population which is the same as the mean of the distribution of sample means.
And let's say this is two standard deviations away from the mean which is the
same as the mean plus 2 times the standard error. And this value here is the
mean minus 2 times the standard error. Now, 95% are between these two values.
So, getting back to this example, 95% of means are within two of these standard
deviations on either side of the population mean. This distance, 2 times the
population standard deviation divided by root n, is called the margin of error.
So now, what does that tell us about this value of 40? If everyone started using
the Bieber Tweeter, we're guessing that there'd be a new population distribution
of Klout scores, but we don't know what it would be. But we do know that one of
the samples of size 35 has a mean of 40. Now, if 95% of sample means are within
2 times the standard error, then this mean value has a 95% chance of being
within 2 times the standard error of this new population mean, if everyone used
the Bieber Tweeter.